- Well, you've got a film with
Dwayne Johnson next, right?
- [Sarah] Yes. It's a superhero movie.
It's called "Black Adam."
- [Kelly] (gasps) I'm into it.
- And he plays Black Adam.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And, you know, I think he was one
of the only ones without the muscle suit.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(audience laughing)
- He didn't need any help.
But yeah, it comes out next July.
- That's exciting.
Have you always want to
do a superhero thing?
I love superhero stuff.
- You know? I mean, no.
I always wanted to play, like,
the hooker with a heart
of gold who's like,
(audience laughing)
you know, it's like, you know...
- Why'd she look at me
when she said that, though?
(laughing)
- I didn't mean it like that.
- I mean, I'm a hooker but
no heart of gold, for sure.
- Ahhh!
- [Kelly] Yes you do.
- [Sarah] Oh, I Just,
you know, just like, you know,
crying and laughing at
the same time, whatever.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Juxtaposition of things.
- That's funny, 'cause
that's how comedians--
I want to play a serious role.
People never want to see me serious.
- [Sarah] Right, right,
right. Right, yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- But I-- So, it was
not something I ever--
(Leslie laughing)
- No, that's true, though.
That's true. But actually,
- Kelly was like "oh."
- [Kelly] No, because you know
why? Why I'm saying that--
I actually find that comedians
are usually very intelligent,
very witty, and very deep.
So usually, like, this--
- And on every level.
And we have to know every level,
'cause we perform for different people.
Like this audience,
I would have to know how to
perform for each one of you.
So yeah.
- Exactly, and I actually
think that's why I said, "Oh,"
'cause I was like,
"Actually I would love
you in a serious role."
- Man.
- Because I think that comedians
do really well in that--
- They do.
- And I get why you'd want it.
See, I hate acting, but if
I was going to be an actor,
I would want to be
Kathy Bates in "Misery".
- [Leslie] Oh, yeah.
- [Sarah] Right, right.
- That's a good one.
- 'Cause no one's seeing it coming.
- Sledgehammer.
- I want to play crazy.
- I'd be, yeah. Yeah.
Just carry it around.
[Sarah] Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- I want to be crazy, and
just in a frigging weird way.
- Yeah, I want to play a serial killer,
or something like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah! That sounds fun.